afternoon this talk is outside the usual
range of the talks here it's partly
about microarchitecture and the design
of chips and it's partly about the
exploits but particular the so called
specter exploit those of you who have
any real expertise in either
microarchitecture or Specter will
realize that I am grossly
oversimplifying for a more general
audience and in fact lying through my
teeth but I'd be more than happy to go
to it in greater detail and at the end
of the talk this URLs to some places
where you can in fact get a la whole lot
more of the details if you wish now this
is actually a story and the story of
course has characters and all good
stories have to have a villain so as
this is dealing with exploits and the
bad guys coming in and stealing secrets
well our story has to have a villain and
villains always have a lair that they
hang out in but there are the characters
in particular there's the ingenue and
her residence and of course there's the
chest which holds the secrets and the
secret itself now our story begins the
secret is located in the chest and the
chest is located in the residence and if
you want to think about this in machine
terms the secret is a perhaps a crypto
key and the chest is a dram or your hard
drive and the residence is the CPU now
the villain is the one who wants to
acquire the secrets and he's in his lair
which is some other system sends
messages to the Entre Nous
in her residence asking for favors show
her hands how many here have ever either
sent or received in your whole life
a real live telegram
Wow
he will in fact ask for the secret but
of course she's aware of this it's just
say no if he does our plot
well the villain is going to try and get
the Entre Nous to open the chest pull
out the secret and move the secret into
her residence
that is move it up from wherever it's
stored into the CPU and then he's going
to attempt to move it to his lair where
he can that's cond part of these steps
to open the chest and move the things
into the city into the residence is
called access separately the steps of
moving it from run residence back to the
lair is called X filtration all exploits
involve both sides of this and many
people and you'll see an awful lot of
comment on the web confuse these two
notions but in fact they're quite
distinct and what has to be done to
defend about them is different now to
steal a secret we must first cause the
secret owner the end of the Entre Nous
to access it and bring it into the CPU
because the villain has got no way
assuming that he does not physically
have the machine in its possession he's
got no way to access the disk or memory
to exfiltrate it he must then caught
force the Arsenal to do something with
the secret in a way that leaves tracks
the origin who is not gonna let him get
at the secret but if there's tracks
maybe the villain can find out from the
tracks what the secret value actually
was you can stop such an attack in
either of by blocking the access or the
exfiltration
historically most of the CPU chips all
the ones in your laptops here and
massive servers and what-have-you they
all permit easy access because that's
required to get performance at least in
the traditional microarchitectures the
designers thought that they were safe
because they were had blocked
exfiltration they didn't care about the
access because both steps are required
unfortunately Spectre proven them that
they were wrong I'm going to walk you
through a particular flavor of Spectre
Spectre actually is a whole family of
attacks that worked in recognizably
similar ways using different aspects of
the machine but this is just one of them
again if you want all the details as an
Earl at the end to a very good
presentation of the details we'll assume
that I'm Janu has got some public
functions that the villain can call so
for example let's assume that this is a
public function and the option is code
now this code may be a fragment of a
normal piece of code they're just that
does does something completely different
those things are called gadgets of a
point of historical incidents the the
plutonium or uranium core inside the
atomic bombs dropped on Japan the core
was known but by the people in the
Manhattan Project as a gadget and
whether there is any historical
connection to the use of an exploit
gadget and in our context I don't know
but it is interesting the code may come
from a JIT it may be just something
there doesn't really matter but it does
mean that the villain can call it and
call it with a whole bunch of arguments
and if you look closely at what that
code is doing that argument is being
used as a subscript to a-1 and
consequently the
villain and use absolutely any value as
an argument and will then be able by
subscripting the array will then be able
to access any location in memory note
we're talking a C or assembly language
here or even the binary that we're
assuming that you're not working at a
high level language the a sub X we have
you any address you want he still has to
get it back because all that's done is
loaded into the on Jindo CPU so the
Angela new doesn't want him to be able
to force access anywhere so she tests
the arguments and inserts a perfectly
ordinary bounce cut if she didn't insert
text rebounds jacket that's not Spector
that's just a bug now when the villain
bangs on it well he gets back zeros and
zeros and zeros for all the areas
outside of the a one that he's supposed
to be being able to get access to
through the API that the option who is
exporting but when he puts a value as an
argument in which is within bounds he's
good he get he gets whatever this thing
in boots and by putting in the bounce
Jack the osman who has blocked him out
of everything he's not supposed to be
able to get maybe
the problem is what's called speculative
execution which is a characteristic of
all out-of-order machines which includes
essentially all high-end existing course
it is not in fact something which was
done in low-end the z80 for example
doesn't do it how many people have ever
programmed for the 8000 or than do
telegrams but they if this is a hardware
characteristic this is not something the
compiler does it's not something
operating system does it's not something
that the entre news code does it this is
something the hardware does whether you
want it or not the test looks like it
does this first it compares the bounds
and branches and possibly returns then
it does the access of a1 and the access
of a2 and whatever else it does that
branch is what would make things safe
unfortunately modern hardware doesn't
actually do this what it does is it does
the bounds compare then it does the
accesses and maybe a whole bunch more
and only then does it do the branch and
verify that you are in fact within
bounds this has been reordered the
operations and done them out of order
and ahead and this is why it's called
run run ahead speculative execution
there's your branch this is not under
the control of the Asha knew as a result
of this reordering the villain can
access a one sub anywhere because we
went and did the access before we
discovered that we were out of bounds
speculative education well how do you
get from this to this
the branch takes a long time the loads
with the accesses take a long long long
time in machine terms and
microarchitecture people don't like
things that take a long long long long
time so the solution that has been
developed initially starting with Thomas
Zulu and the three sixty ninety one over
fifty years ago it but basically the
solution is you do them both at once not
necessarily an order and then figure it
out later and after you have all the
things in hand that is the reorder and
the speculative execution question is
then the hardware know-how to try this
as opposed to the other well it knows
because the last few times that it did
at this code the branch did not go to
the return so in the hardware there's a
whole hunk of hardware and gates called
the branch predictor that says what did
you do last time but I think you're
going to do the same thing next time and
it predicts that the branch will not be
taken and let's other things go ahead
without actually checking it the check
will happen eventually and everything
will get undone well most things will
get undone but it will start the a the a
one access right away because it
predicts that in fact is what's it's
going to need to do of course you can
drive the branch predictor any way you
like if the villa remember the villain
if the villain seeps sending the same in
veins by you
over and over and over and over again
the branch predictor which is watching
what he's doing will say oh I finally
gotten the idea the next time he does it
he's going to be within bounds and go
and do the right thing again except he
sends one that is not within back
and sure enough the Arjun who opens the
memory chest there and more corrected
the speculating hardware has and we have
accessed the secret even though the
access is in fact incorrect the
predictor said we think we're going to
do this now in our story so far the
villain has trained the branch predictor
to expect valid important than assent
invalid run ahead speculating hardware
is a speculative really executed the
predicted access the secret has now been
laid there but it's still only in the
arms renews core now we have to
exfiltrate it back out to the lair if
you remember the arms in those original
code that part the access to a one is
for access this part is for exfiltration
and this is what makes spectre so
deviously clever you'll see how it works
the villain uses the cash to exfiltrate
by using the secret and in an address
you'll note that a one sub X is the
secret and we're using that secret value
as a subscript in another memory
reference and so the secret is now part
of the address in the reference to a -
so the secret value is used to calculate
the address and the secret value is zero
that calculated address will be a 2
because as a 2 sub 0 and if the secret
value is 1 the calculated address will
be a 2 plus 64 you notice the time 64
there and 128 and you get the idea in
terms of cash lines instead of bytes and
if the secret is zero we'll go to the
line that contains
the secret is one it'll go to the line
the next line after the line that
contains a two or plus one line and plus
two lines and so forth
now the cache is a two-dimensional array
of bytes copied from memory caches
whereas the great innovation in the 70s
and 80s and what essentially what made
modern processes be able to do what they
do a typical high level cache have lines
which are typically 64 bytes and though
there's an immense amount of variety
here and typically one will contain 512
different lines and/or a total to 32 KB
this is merely typical that I recommend
the Wikipedia article on caching which
actually does a very good job on it now
if the line that you were accessing
happens to be one that is in the cache
that is is the address you're using is
is addressing one of the lines in the
cache your access will be fast this is
the whole point behind the cache if the
line address is not in cache we're
probably going to go all the way to DRAM
and in machine terms that is glacial so
in order to speed everything up if you
access the line that is not in cache it
will be brought in and placed in cache
tossing something else out this is made
use of in the exfiltration first the
villain repeatedly accesses memory and
accesses memory and accesses memory to
accesses which are valid in the victor
in the villains space but which will
wind up in the different cache lines in
the physical cache so the there we go
the villain succeeds in loading 512 of
the villains valid lines into cache
what flushing out
anything else that had been there then
he does the access now the effect of
that address access is the Oz news hard
we'll run ahead picks up the hardware in
for purposes of the slide say that the
secret value is two figures the ad the
address of a two plus two lines runs out
to D ramen gets it pulls the thing in
and it gets put in the cash that's the
hardware doing it it's not the program
doing it the expectation of the hardware
is that he's good that somebody is going
to do look at something else in this
line again and again and again and
having it the cash will speed the
program up and in general this is true
eventually the hardware figures out the
branch predictor it was wrong and
everything that it did speculatively
it's tossed and it returns the zero but
not quite everything because in fact
what happens is it leaves the cash
changes because it doesn't really have
anything else to put in that line is
that what was in there before it's been
thrown away and who knows maybe that
line will be needed and so it doesn't
bother getting rid of it meanwhile back
at the lair which is probably an SMT
thread that the villain is running or
happens to be on the same a cloud
machine that the the azure new is
running on when he gets control back
remember it will return the zero because
the access was out of range the cache
now looks like this all but one of the
lines has the value that the villain put
in there one of the lines which actually
contains a secret but he can't get at
because the address is wrong it's
different so the villain proceeds to run
through the same set of addresses that
he used to fill the cache looking at
each line one at a time and he measures
the time at text
do the read well when he goes to the
first line and does the read it's fast
because the that that line was in fact
in cash and bingo
here's your response and again when he
hits it again but when he gets to the
line that has the on shinu's line in it
it's not fast because he is trying to
read his line that's not what's there
and the hardware will run all the way
out to DRAM and will take a long long
time compared to the other cache
accesses for that value to be brought in
so he measures the times and he notices
that when he read line two it was slow
which means that the secret line had to
have been the one put in line two and
you you think back about how that
address was computed that means that the
secrets value was two because that
determined what the value got but which
line got updated that is extremely
devious we know the secret value is 2
and exfiltration and access have been
accomplished exit villain it turns out
that if you on a conventional modern
machine using this technique and you
want to pull up a 256 byte key you can
do that in 10 milliseconds using this
technique from anywhere in the answer
lose address space some details
it's a family they all members of the
family depend on running to have
speculation the exfiltration Bevans very
including their effectiveness and how
much trouble it is to get everything set
up to work right again I refer you to
the Earl at the end the hardware
speculation is essential for the
performance of virtually all high-end
microarchitectures produced by many many
vectors there any machine that does not
do run ahead speculation is immune to
Spector it may be vulnerable to other
things but the entire Spector family
will be immune to the immune ones
include most low end machines if any
eight or 16-bit machines do will not be
doing road ahead speculation and
especially in the embedded world many of
the even the larger machines do not do
speculation now what what can you do
about it I mean your hardware vendor
what can you do it to begin with it is
trivially easy to fix specter just don't
do run ahead and this is usually a
fairly thing easy thing to do you
reflash the bios and flip a bit
somewhere in the thing and who doesn't
do a speculation anymore
and you will hit a sizable performance
penalty on most applications now
alternatively you can add explicit
instructions to temporarily shut down
speculation in a vulnerable area of code
perhaps bracketing that gadget you'll
still have some performance penalty and
then you're left with the problem of how
do you figure out where it is that
somebody is going to make that attack
and get the correct software corrections
in the right place yes well good luck
with that you can just use a programming
tool that doesn't let speculative values
be used in addresses you still have a
performance penalty but there are other
at this point something like fifteen or
sixteen different methods known in the
Spector family to do exfiltration not
involving the cache addressing at all
there is a lot of that been going around
for the past year fixing it is easy just
don't do run ahead what's hard is how to
do run ahead and get performance and
this is where the microarchitecture
comes in now I work with the mill CPU
architecture some you know who's heard
about the mill we're getting out there
folks and well it is very different and
I'm going to show you how we get high
performance in a non run ahead
environment there are other possible
approaches but the traditional run ahead
is clearly not working and the intel's
and AMD's and arms of the world are
happy to do some very rich serious
rethinking both architectural ii and in
in the marketplace a typical memory
hierarchy looks vaguely something like
this this is highly abstract and the
real world is rather different and has a
whole lot of details glossed over here
when we issue a load the first place
that we look is in the top level cache
and access to time for that is typically
something around three cycles if we do
not find the value in the high top level
cache we go to the next level cache l2s
is typically something ten maybe twelve
cycles eventually we run out of cash and
we go to DRAM and you're looking at 300
or more this is why there's caches this
is why this run ahead memory latency is
the reason for speculation if you can
start a load early and you can be doing
the effects while the course doing other
things so if I have other stuff and then
I do a load of X and then I use X the
use being a consumer then I can do get
better performance if I start the load
then I do other stuff then I end the
load and then I use it the mill has
what's called a deferred load which
explicitly splits the front and back of
this these are actually in some cases
two different operations separated by a
fair amount of potentially in many many
cycles in time in other cases and the
one they'll show you here we just simply
say how long we want to wait
implementation details in that video
there's 20 odd hours worth of detailed
architectural videos on our website
available for you now the load problem
is one that we all face if you do an ADD
and then a load and you then you shift
the value picking stuff out and then you
store it what you will actually get is
the hardware will do the add and then
it'll start the load
and it'll stall because the load value
isn't available to do the shift and
it'll stall and it'll stall and then for
a change it will stall and finally I'll
get around to retiring of value to you
and doing the show and we carry on at
that point every architecture has to
deal with this problem it is
fundamentally I when the fact that CPU
speeds were wound up increasing
dramatically over the years and memory
speeds do not keep up with them Mill
deferred loads the generic mill
operation well it slowed up code and
there's the address which is the usual
address stuff for an address format we
say how why did the value that we one
load is and that's part of the operation
and then we add another unusual argument
which is the delay the number of cycles
that we want to have to wait before the
retire becomes available so if I do a
load there and I put four in that value
then I can do an instruction anything I
can do instruction I can to do an
instruction and then finally four cycles
later the load retires and at that point
I can put to my consumer note that the
load and four cycles of other stuff of
overlaps so that if we actually got the
value out of the d1 which takes three
cycles that value was already there when
the consumer gets around asking for it
top speed all the way through the data
becomes available at the point of the
consumer when the load issues there the
retire is deferred for the four
instructions now if we reorder our code
and you talk to compiler into doing it
or your hand assembler you can rewrite
things so that you can put separate the
loads issue from the loads retire by
more so for example if this is our code
that hides one stall because there's one
operation in between the load and the
consumer but I can hoist the load over
prior operations like that and now I'm
hiding two stalls similarly I can lower
the consumer over something else down to
there
now I hide three stalls and my access to
cash was free top local cash again if
we're going to do Ram everybody is going
to be slow Mill - there are constraints
to reorder obviously you can't lower a
horse to consumer over its own producer
because the data flow has to be
preserved but in addition producers and
consumers have side channels to
communicate with each other through
other things going on in passing back
and forth into memory where this is not
all happening in core because one
producer can I have stores intermixed
with the loads that it wants to do but
the hardware knows that the addresses
that are used are the same then this is
called aliasing and is a fundamental
problem in microarchitecture design is
what do you do about aliasing and this
is percolated back up into programming
languages and such that you can by
adding pragmas or some other feature of
a language ascertain an alias is in fact
not possible and the hardware will then
happen they use the compiler will then
happily hoist things up but in general
the compiler cannot tell whether
hoisting is possible over a load over a
store and must be defensive and assume
the worst case but as a matter of actual
practice false true aliasing is very
rare in code and so nearly always when
the compiler is being defensive the
compiler is in fact suffering from false
aliasing and there was no need to be
defensive it's just the compiler can't
tell I write compilers
well in the abstract sense for all
architectures a load sees memory as of a
certain point in time in the sequence of
changes that get made to the memory it
sees the effects of stalls of stores
that happened before that point of time
and it does not see the effect of stores
which happen after that point of time
exactly where that point of time is is
part of the semantics of the hardware
and which again percolates up into the
programming language and sometimes a
hardware will say well we're not really
sure whether you can see it or not and
this gives you leads you into the more
acid as memory models on the mill loads
C memory as of the retire of the load
not as of the issue of the load but as
of the retire of the load so if the
instruction says with the delay of seven
yes this means don't bother me with an
area where the result in for in for
seven cycles and then give me the sia
the result and I can be doing seven
cycles worth of stuff while you're
running out trying to get a value for me
but it also means give me a value as it
will be seven cycles from now as a
result we are immune to aliases
because issues now may be hosted over
stores including those which are true
aliases because that's not the value
that the hardware is going to return to
you it's going to return to the value
after those stores at the point where
the load retires this is part of the
architecture of the mill it's done in
hardware and you don't have to worry
about it the compiler knows that the
memory value will be that puts the load
in with the memory values so that it
will be seeing the right things in the
stores if this was the original code
with the retire there as modified
clear
same semantics same value loaded this is
exactly what the hardware run ahead is
doing except there's no speculation and
no run ahead even if the store is the
same address of course there's more
problems in stores you also can get in
trouble take this little fragment here
you we can speculatively do this we load
both of them the pick operators choose
one of two and on the mill and and pick
will select one of the two and then we
use that address to in the store but if
we do do it like this
well what happens if P or Q happen to be
a null pointer we are loading both to
speculate for in order to get
performance but one of these is
unnecessary we don't know which one and
we are potentially OOP Singh because
we're dereferencing a null pointer that
in fact if we executed the thing in
order we would never in fact touch
because the B would have protected that
but we're speculating for performance
and we are in fact issuing both of them
at once the no Lowood fault even if it
was not used and that we really don't
want to do that the mill solution for
this problem is to augment every
operator operand in the core with an
extra bit called the not a result or
Norbit in its metadata this bit is set
on every value its produce which
whenever the operations determined that
they cannot produce a valid result the
sign that magnet assigned overflow for
shifts loads with nova knoll addresses
anything in which folks this value is
bogus what you get back is an R with the
the
so if the operation runs - okay you'll
get a perfectly ordinary value.we with a
clear dinar bet and that the operation
does Anoop say you will get an R which
has the Narvik set and the remaining
values of the operand contain a payload
in which one part tells you what it was
that went wrong and one part tells you
where it happened and the debugger does
a pretty good job of telling you where
the fault happened not where we
discovered that things had gone wrong
but where the fault happened now
operations divided into two kinds a
specular bull operation has got no side
effects an ad for example and if it gets
in an R it propagates those nars so an
RN will lead to an hour result but will
not lead to a fault this is true whether
it's a scalar or vector the vector the
individual elements of the vector have
nah rabbits and so you can do an
operation which will propagate the nars
as well as computing that the correct
results for the other elements typical
speculoos small ad shift pick what have
you a non-spectral little operation is
something that's got side effects
there's nothing we can do we can't do
the side effects we don't know whether
the value is valid so we fault you're
now in your fault handler and software
and whatever your host language or
runtime system does with that well we do
hardware marketing of my hardware
microarchitecture and your runtime
system is somebody else's problem now if
you compare these different approaches
in order your z80 it is immune if you
have anything where you really care
about security this is a very good
choice to use it's slow it's very
low-power extremely economical and
dirt-cheap
like seven cents apiece and volume so it
if you care about security see if you
could find a chip which is in order a
conventional chip using one raw run
ahead the x86 Azure whatever that's in
your laptops they are unsafe they are
faster the run ahead did by something
the power consumption is extremely high
out of order or processing in the
microarchitecture is very very expensive
compared to an inorder machine with the
same but rough capability if you
mitigate that well it may be more secure
it will certainly be slower and the
power remains high if you mitigate it
all the way down you've now spent a
whole lot of power to do out of order
that you're not using mill immune fast
faster than than the regular chips that
you're getting and low power because
it's in order and do not it does not
have to have the out of order logic we
were not designed to be immune to
Spector and the design long pre debts of
discovery of spectrum instead that mill
design was make it simple and
transparent I encourage you to take a
look at some of our videos and you'll
see how we how we went about that and
what the result was we did not in we
rejected out of hand complex techniques
like SMT and run ahead on the other hand
the next attack and for sure there are
more attacks out there it may hit the
mill - we were just frankly lucky that
we were immune to Spectre on the other
hand being simple and transparent makes
it less likely that we will be
vulnerable to
Jack's complex tends to make holes so
the mill protection model you only see
what I give you I can only see what you
give me the mill is designed for a a a
microkernel OS fast and cheap no third
parties in the basic principle for
security it must be unobtrusive
unavoidable and cheap and it won't be
used and if you see the alternatives
that are being offered to you for
improving the security and your laptops
cell phones servers they're not
unobtrusive they're not unavoidable and
they're very much not cheap they are
little story some credits the villain
was played by Eric Campbell if he looks
familiar to you he played the father of
the girl or the policeman and many of
the Charlie Chaplin shorts the layer of
course is not revealed although I
encourage you to see the next the sequel
of our story and perhaps you'll be able
to see where the layer is on that one
the aunjanue is Mary Pickford she was
well known for playing on to new roles
in the silent film era the residences
the dailies guesthouse which is part of
a park in Santa Monica was originally
built sort of as a present by an
extremely much person for an actress
named Marion Davies it was just a small
thing and had a hundred and ten rooms
the the picture actually is only of a
guest house the original the the real
mansion was torn down in the 50s in
order to put up a parking lot
the specter victims in alphabetical
order and the hero of it all naturally
enough if we have got a whole pile of
publicly published information that we
are extremely unusual compared to most
vendors and that we tell you how it
works and in sufficient detail and your
and as I said this 20 odd hours worth of
video and a whole lot of other stuff
available on the site if you're looking
for more details about Spectre itself
I recommend John masters paper and it
goes into considerable detail of
explanation of many of the variations
and you can get it at there a disclaimer
we're not security experts we didn't
foresee it serendipitous
it is easier to avoid things when things
are simple and sometimes you get lucky
we got lucky thank you
[Applause]
I do Warner did somebody get that are
there any questions on the slide him he
said if not I'll take questions from the
floor don't all speak at once the mill
CPU is a general purpose CPU family like
the 360 was a family the there is a
lower bound in terms of what the
microarchitecture can do it is basically
a 64-bit machine you could not do a
16-bit mill for various micro
architectural reasons there is at the
high end of the family the gold
processor which is probably the highest
one that we will actually produce as a
product can issue 31 operations per
cycle on an ongoing continuous basis
again that's the high-end the internal
architecture if you lift the hood it
looks like nothing you have ever seen
anybody who's been in our videos knows
what I'm talking about and I encourage
you to do it's not a one-trick pony and
I can't just say oh well it's because
this there's 20 hours of videos there I
encourage you to tackle them one by one
in order that speculating ahead indeed
other questions anyway I'd love to brag
about the baby and if you want a button
hold me I'm more than happy to give you
in all the depth you possibly want any
details that you desire thank you
you